hello my name is Peter Stillwell from
the united states and i was wondering at
john mavar would be so kind as to help
me understand whether entry knows have
mass and different energy states and
whether that changes so i'm not really
sure how much subatomic particle physics
are in his field but you can answer that
I'd be grateful thank you so Peter still
while is asking the question about do
Danitra neutrinos have mass well
neutrinos were first discovered they
were discovered because they carried
away energy and momentum from nuclear
reactions and we couldn't explain them
unless we could imagine that these
particles would exist everything we
could tell at the time was that
neutrinos had no mass they traveled at
the speed of light or are very nearly
but then in recent times we've seen
evidence that they do have mass it's
only very small so the way that we found
out was number one we know that the Sun
makes neutrinos and we were not getting
the right number of neutrinos here on
earth in our detectors so we had to
imagine that the neutrinos were turning
into something else on the way so the as
it seems to be true the neutrinos that
are manufactured in the sun by nuclear
reactions are turning into a different
kind of neutrino before they get here
and so that's why we couldn't see them
all similar things now have been
observed with neutrinos that we might
manufacture in nuclear reactors and so
it seems to be true neutrinos do have
mass it's very small but it can be
measured a little bit and this is a very
difficult measurement it's but we're
pretty sure neutrinos have mass